know we got that we got these stories
get gamertag you know i want to get into
new stuff but i do want to celebrate one
thing obviously you know how important
was it for you you know what i mean as
far as being not only the first
gaming podcaster but also the first
latino to be inducted into podcast hall
of fame brother
uh it means a lot to me man because
again you know i went through a lot
back in the days you know
growing up
especially in new york um
and not having the money to to buy the
equipment you know i i bought a a
computer
in my mid-20s man like super late
uh because i just didn't have the money
you know i had to get a student loan and
that's how i started using my uh i
created my show back then because of
that so
seeing that
and
also just having fun with my podcast man
you know uh
it mean the show means a lot to me man
like look now
i'm i started working at g4 yes just
been it's gonna be now a week you know
and
seeing that and all the stuff that i
learned from the show
it means a lot it's now i want to see
the next con the next generation of
content creators and even podcasters too
to do everything and take it to the next
level i want you to be even better than
me man you know and uh and seeing look
seeing
everything that's been going on with not
only with me but my brothers you know uh
pete and paris like dude i cried when i
saw paris on stage brother stage with
xbox showcase man because yo
people don't know the struggle that we
went to man you know like that moment
that video you people got to see
of paris excited about cyberpunk at that
time at e3 yeah you know i did that
because
paris was going
he was going through so much during that
time man and
that moment for me was special because i
whined my i want my brother to be happy
man
and be excited and i want the world to
see that so i recorded that
and i posted it online and those videos
went viral yeah i wasn't thinking of
like oh click bait and i was thinking
like yo i want to know if my brother is
good celebrated you know so
so seeing him on stage dude i broke down
live live on the stream man broke down
you know fantastic that's fantastic i
broke down when i got my award
you know um again because people don't
know when i went through manchester
united and full circle man seeing
you know my face on a billboard
new york city let's go new york city
in times square man
i was like dude that was like amazing
man because i i just got proposed like
engaged i mean the proposed my my fiance
and that month came back went to new
york straight because i wanted to see my
billboard and she recorded my reaction
again i almost cried again man people
don't know the stuff that i've been
through man i've seen that and i was
there 20 years ago with a tape cassette
from that same
spot same spot across the street where
torso used to be yes
see my billboard there dude that was
amazing man and and people don't know i
even tried to record an issue with bill
gates
uh and uh because the media was
recording and asking me questions i have
my tape recorder like this
right talk like even asking a question
he was answering one of the questions
while i was recording pr got to see it
yo they grabbed my tape recorder took
the tape and they're like yo but at that
time i didn't know
i didn't know
i didn't know at that time so things
like that dude things like that and and
you know the little sony silver one you
maybe you learned the tdk
actually i can't imagine
the mindset where you're sitting there
i can't imagine the mindset you're
sitting there recording and then just
someone did they like ask you for it do
they take it themselves like yeah they
just ran down on you they ran down you
pulled the chair
you know why i want to mention this i
want to mention this is super important
for those are watching dudes when i came
into the industry dude there was no
latinos there was no
people of color involvement
so it was it was hard for me man because
i felt alone there was no way for me to
learn about the industry like
how to get in like i had to do
everything on my own but when
i managed to figure it out and i get
people like paris hitting me up and
others counter creators at that time
like yo how should i do i also helped
him up because i didn't have that back
then man that's the key i'm saying so
seeing where paris is at
and p and tony and you guys and
everybody else dude that's helping the
next generation
are gonna do the same exact thing that
we're doing you know what i'm saying so
that that's why getting the award
means a lot because
now i'm inspiring a whole new generation
dude you know what i'm saying yeah
i could jump in for a second yes please
yeah um
to speak on that about about you know
how obviously you know being dominican
is super important to you and and i know
you've done work to sort of promote
gaming in santo domingo as well as in
the city like bringing different aspects
of gaming and kind of opening up you
know our cultures to it in a way that
they haven't been opened up before so if
you could talk a little bit about the
stuff that you've done in regards to
that like yeah
that means a lot to me man because um
you know after i i came back to the
states i haven't been in dr for a long
time you know and uh i went there
a couple years ago and i wanted to meet
the gimmick community i want to see how
it is now you know i know it's a lot of
and xbox nintendo switch nintendo games
out there so
i met the gaming community and the one
thing that everybody was telling me like
yo we feel left out we feel left out
there's no
there's no way for us to learn how to
how to uh how to create content there's
no way for us to learn about development
danny you're in it how can you help us
how you can help our our community over
here
and uh i took that
and i had in my head for for like a good
two three years man and i started
talking to
my friends at unity
and i told them yo can we do like a free
workshop because there's a lot of
talented people in the american republic
how we could do that and uh and we went
and we did a whole free
workshop games developer game developer
day we called it and we did at one of
the biggest universities in the american
republic
and i i talked about my story you know
there's a lot of people that never heard
of what i do right and after that dude
there was a whole line of people that
just want to talk to me take pictures
with me
i show them i showed them my story i
told them like look
ubisoft put us put us in the division
two game we're there our logos in the
game like meeting bill gates like i told
them all the story never like wow the
hall of fame store and everything
so that's the thing that i i've been
trying to do is
is inspired not only the consecrative
side but also game developers man over
there
that day they were showing me all these
games that they made over there wow and
i'm like yo this could be on like
platforms big platforms all these
consoles it's so dope man and there's
other countries not only dominican
public but there's other people
that feel the same way
so i've been trying my best to
contribute as much as i can to help just
latin america in general man yeah i'm
saying so absolutely
so that's that's that's that's the main
reason why i've been doing a lot of that
stuff man brother tremendous story
so many iconic moments you've literally
interviewed or rubbed shoulders with the
best of the best the who's who
games media executive tv stars actors
the late great michael k williams i saw
that one um oh yes you know
yeah rest in peace rest in peace john
carla and then we got giancarlo esposito
you know drink chance i mean the
accolades are so immense um i know
you've had a lot of stories and we're
gonna get you out of as far as our top
five that we always ask everyone but
before that i did want to ask you just
personal so many stories it's so many
right but like
we said podcast hall of fame i'm
assuming that might be up there but like
give me just three
moments where you s you sat back and was
like wow
that was amazing whether it be just
personal whether it be or just epic
stories across your journey for you
besides the interviews there's a lot of
answers but
i remember
talking to pete
paris was not part of gtr was he was
doing his own thing at that time
i want to do a an event a event for our
community and uh we did that we rented a
club we did it multiple times right but
there was one year that we did it during
super bowl weekend in south florida okay
right
we had the event we had a 2k sponsor us
they were promoting a bioshock 2 at that
time
and we had tournaments call of duty
gears everything right but remember in
the middle of super bowl weekend there's
tons of events happening at that time in
miami right absolutely yo the day before
our event i go
and i search just to see what people are
talking about our event called community
vibes five okay i go there online
and
the miami new times
named us
the number one super bowl party in south
florida remember wow we were broke as
hell we only had
enough money to
to work what we have for the event
and the one of the biggest newspapers in
miami
put us as number one higher than pepsi
and playboy and like i was like what is
the like that's
the second of course the the times
square build course like
iconic um and i don't want to mention
the the hall of fame because you know
that's like of course of course of
course kids
face on that billboard yeah you made it
you made it yeah you made it
um and just and honestly just um
i think seeing seeing paris on stage man
could that i feel like that's that's
part of me man you know what i'm saying
that's your brother yeah yeah yeah
seeing that was uh what was iconic man
rather tremendous history